[Music]
the idea of a human exoskeleton is not
new concept drawings dating back to the
19th century reveal the depth of our
desire to create a mobile suit that can
give us superhuman powers GE attempted
just that in the 1960s when they
invented the world's first powered
exoskeleton the hardy man however it
required far too much power to work and
was always tethered to a plug in the
last decade due to breakthroughs in
power efficiency and battery capacity
truly mobile exoskeletons are walking
out of the prototype phase and into our
daily lives one of the things that I've
learned being in a wheelchair is that
the world looks down at you and people
don't mean to but you're not at eye
level with anyone so when I'm an XO I
can stand and have a conversation - hi -
hi two weeks before high school
graduation I was 18 years old five
friends and myself were driving to a
friend's lake house we were driving late
at night and there was road construction
they didn't mark the road or even have
construction signs out I didn't see the
turn coming and I drove straight off a
600 foot cliff Ekso bionics is basically
ground zero for exoskeletons so we do
all the design work here they do all the
manufacturing here we do prototyping
here we do testing here and the early
days we try to find what we call our
test pilots to help us evaluate and
improve the exoskeleton I like first
flight as first time using exoskeletons
each test pilot is paired up with a
trained physical therapist who closely
monitors the test pilots movements and
guides them through the rehabilitation
process
so the actual skeleton helps support
Matt to stand up with that the
exoskeleton legs are the external
support for him and actually distributes
the weight of the device through the
ground and then it allows Matt to
actually weigh power through his own
bones
we have adjustability in the lower leg
in the upper leg what you see here is
the hip motor and a knee motor that
actually helps the power the leg and
actually replicates the muscles we have
lithium-ion batteries as the power
source and a computer that's essentially
the backpack so there's an interface on
the crutch that helps Matt to be more
autonomous with the walking he can
initiate that walk cycle shift his
weight find that balance point trigger
his first initial step I'd been in a
wheelchair for three years before I
first walked in EXO and that day that I
got to stand again was very emotional
there was a mission at the end of the
day and we wanted to make a robot that
helped people and I was excited to be
part of the team that did that so I see
a future Dax of skeletons where people
are grabbing him out of the garage to go
on a run through the mountains so they
can cover much more ground because of
the EXO I think there's a ton of
applications for him in the future and
it's just the more we can get it out
there the more ubiquitous today since
February 2012 they have helped people
take more than 17 million steps that
would have otherwise been impossible in
the next five years we could be seeing
exoskeletons in construction sites all
over the world eventually they will be
so lightweight our clothes will be lined
with necks or skeletons that make us
stronger and faster
one day this technology could replace
the wheelchair altogether for now
exoskeleton designers are taking it one
step at a time
as someone who's benefited from wearing
an exoskeleton robot I look at the
future and I see it's very bright
wearing exoskeletons to me
and 20 years is going to be a normal
thing like putting on pants in the
morning instead of transferring into my
wheelchair I'll just get up and it'll be
a daily thing for me and I'll have a
normal active life one more cyborg
nation then hit that subscribe button
from military suits to industrial
exoskeletons to Mexico Mexico Mexico
oh there's Mexico exoskeletons